okay hi everyone um doesn't help that
the the talk in front of me was called
how did you how you can teach JavaScript
because today I'm actually gonna talk
about JavaScript I thought I was gonna
talk at J's cough but unfortunately I
got put on CSS cause I know for a fact
that you can do 3d on the web with CSS
but that's not something that I'm gonna
talk about today so apologize for those
who has that idea so about me my name is
Sheila I am a developer advocate and all
the desk so all of this is a 3d computer
software company if you guys don't know
so basically we have built a lot of
products around 3d and also in the
browser so I was I just wanted to show
you guys this today so I'm gonna go
through a very simple and very small
example for for writing 3d on the web
and it's basically gonna resemble this
I'm gonna only take you through from
step 1 through 4 here and from step 4 to
5 really requires a lot of study and
I'll show you what I exactly mean later
so basically it's really on the web is
WebGL and WebGL 101 it's based on a
WebGL is based on something called open
to you yes it's not the same thing but
it's a very similar syntax if you guys
have any experience it's meant for the
browser's and it's very very difficult
and I'm gonna show you guys exactly what
it is here is a very simple simple
sample code of drawing one triangle with
WebGL it's about 100 lines of code and
you get a triangle like this so if this
is geo programming so it's basically
calling API an API and draws from the
GPU
so if you
doing very graphics heavy stuff on the
browser this is what you want to use and
luckily there are a lot of ways to
simplify this there's a lot of existing
libraries and frameworks that lets you
do this so today I'm just gonna talk
about something that is very versatile
an easier way of 3d on the web so there
are a lot of different libraries to
choose from there's like three J's Babel
and J has a frame it sometimes someone
from Mozilla is gonna talk about a
frames I don't like too thick and steal
their thunder there are game engines
like unity that exports to WebGL but
it's very it's for very very specific
use cases so I'm just gonna talk about
something that's very versatile right
here which is three gears and this is a
link to say so three kids basically
abstract away in triangles in GL
programming instead of doing all that
like this is these three lines are doing
more stuff than what that hundred lines
did back there so in to draw a cylinder
in 3d space you basically specify a
number of triangles that makes up a
cylinder instead of writing all those
triangles by yourself with vertices you
could just vark cylinder equals new 3d
mesh and new cylinder geometry so if you
want to draw a square it's like a score
square of geometry so to get started
with three j/s there are four things
that you need you need asking a scene
camera renderer and your control and you
want to fill stuff in your scene and you
want to animate the scene so that's like
very basic 3d scene things that you need
so here I'm gonna talk about three
functions so the innate function is
gonna init initialize the scene camera
renderer and controls the field ceiling
thing is gonna put stuff in the scene
and then I'm gonna animate it it should
be quite straightforward so in three.js
when you initialize the scene there's a
news and three scene and
you get a camera which is a which I'm
gonna use a perspective camera here is a
very very commonly used 3d camera as
opposed to orthographic camera which is
like viewing 2d on 3d but we don't have
to go to go into deep here you passing a
bunch of variables basically the inner
clipping form complained outer clipping
pointing and how big you want you want
your camera to view and then you passing
the review you instantiate the renderer
and set the color of the renderer and
the size and then for the control here
I'm using again a very generic 3d
control that that is commonly used in 3d
scenes and they in the end you just use
your renderer to render your scene and
camera so in the beginning after you
initialize everything it's very it's
it's just a scene it's it's not special
at all right now so the next step what I
did is you fill seeing basically I've
instantiated a bunch of particles all in
all with the 3js material and this is
very very basic 3d mesh and it's a
particle it's it's the particle geometry
and particle material is you know
basically what you want to passing as
parameters and I said I randomized the
positions and randomized the directions
I want to take because I want to animate
those particles and I add that particles
into the scene so I have a randomized
set of particles in the 3d space we
can't really do anything right now yet
it's still nothing special it's it
doesn't move but we're getting there so
the last thing I want to do is the enemy
animating is less of a actual animating
you want to consider it less as
animating the objects but more to tell
the browser what to do each time it
calls request animation frame so request
animation frame there's something that
you know whenever the browser refreshes
the frame you
it will call the function within
requestanimationframe so in computer
vendor animation it needs to be 60
frames per second and that's exactly
what requests and information frame does
with a lot of graphics programmers they
like still use this at timeout which is
something that I really so basically the
in my code I'm gonna call animate in the
request animation frame function so
again I'm up
I added my control so I I'm updating my
controls and I run a four loop through
each of the particles and I move the
particles every time the the
requestanimationframe is called and then
I also said a boundary where if the
particle reaches an edge it bounces back
so it's still very simple code and I
render it again each time I enemy so
here it's moving very slowly and this is
a 3d scene so I can use orbit controls
so yeah this is still very very basic so
this is a source code and if you want to
get a VR like effect you basically
replace the camera the some of the
parameters in the camera and replace the
control with something called device
orientation controls so basically that
hooks up your camera your your phone or
or VR device orientation with with the
scene so here's the demo if you guys
have cured ghosts and sienar I encourage
you to try it I'm just gonna give you
guys a minute
it's basically goes to a website that I
built for this
so if you have a phone that you
purchased after 2014
you should have 3d enabled and be able
to see it rendered with the devices okay
so everyone got it so again this is step
four to really make really cool
animations in the in a 3d space I'm
gonna show you guys what we've done and
and this may be some inspiration of what
you could really do with three days so
so this is the library that we've both
on top of three years with this is like
a computer-aided design model and and I
mean the browser so you can look at how
just how good the rendering is and the
materials are so you can zoom into each
of the particle where the and basically
look at these engineering drawings and
this was built with a with a industrial
design this model was strong with the
industrial design software so everything
that was in the was in the design
actually got ported into the browser and
and it's the library behind it is three
years and that's why I'm talking about
it today so with this you can basically
where we have tied a bunch of JavaScript
functions with this everything is
basically a JavaScript object so we have
typed a lot of JavaScript functions so
you can do like expo fold or rotate and
this what this basically is doing is
doing a transferring transformation to
your to the object in your 3d scene and
it's just very significant how far we've
gotten to to render 3d and in the
website because in a website because
this we have not done any optim
optimization to render this because we
what we what we do as a company is we do
imaging engineering data so none of
these data can be lost and we do no
optimization to the number of Polly's
like we don't we don't reduce the number
of Polly's in in this drawing so so
there's a bunch of demos we have also
like both a lot of functions with these
type of 3d models you could you could
again like expose exploded or you could
do a sectioning
like you can section this whatever model
3d model you have so sometimes I would
hear people that have touched that
front-end developers that have touched a
little bit on WebGL and said that WebGL
isn't really promising this is like a
proof against that and because this is
again engineering data you have like all
the properties and and all the all the
statistics on on each of the part and
there there's just another thing I
wanted to show you guys what we've both
this is project Apollo and we basically
collaborated with it with the university
and putting the model of the stem space
space capsule and and showed it to the
public and and you can click on their
link and look at everything and honestly
this is really best achieved with WebGL
you can't really do it with anything any
other technology and let's see I just
want to finish off with this beautiful
rendering and that's what also one of
the things that people said about WebGL
is it doesn't have as much textures as
OpenGL however you can really write very
very beautiful rendering and graphics in
the browser okay that's it all my talk
and this is a QR code for the slides if
you guys want to check it out
you
you